لأسابيع، هذا ما رأيناه من
الحرب على
غزة، القوة العسكرية الإسرائيلية الوحشية التي
تقصف الأحياء
في وسط غزة وسانت
وتحولت إلى ركام تبدو وكأنها مهجورة وغير
قابلة للعيش، ولكن هناك أيضًا هذه
المشاهد شبه السريالية في الصخب
والضجيج  من سوق الشارع، إنها قصة
كل حرب حيث لا تتوقف الحياة،
وتستمر بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يحاولون
البقاء على قيد الحياة، لكن غزة ليست مثل أي مكان آخر،
حيث يكتظ أكثر من مليوني شخص
في هذا القطاع الصغير من الأرض
الذي يبدو الآن وكأنه كذلك  تم قصفه مرة
أخرى إلى العصور الماضية حيث لم يبق لأولئك الذين
فقدوا كل شيء أي مكان سوى
الشوارع حيث يقوم موتوس
ببناء فرن من الطين على أمل أن
يدفع له الناس شيكلًا أو اثنين لاستخدامه، كما
يقول، ربما عندها سيكون لديه ما يكفي للشراء
أطفاله الجبن أو الطماطم الذين كان لدي
معظمهم هنا نجوا من القنابل فقط ليقعوا
في فخ هذا
المرض البائس والمجاعة التي حذرت الأمم المتحدة من أنها قد
تقتل قريبًا أكثر من تلك
القنابل التي تقول إنها نصف السكان،
والآن يتضورون جوعًا ويقضون أيامًا كاملة
دون أن يأكلوا أم أحمد يقول  إنها
تجمع القليل من الدقيق من هنا
وهناك لتخبز الخبز
لأطفالها وتقول هيومن رايتس ووتش إن إسرائيل
تستخدم التجويع كسلاح في الحرب،
إنها جريمة حرب تنفيها إسرائيل وتصفها
بالكذب وتتهم حماس بسرقة
المساعدات في أعقاب ذلك.  في 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)،
أعلن وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي عن
حصار غزة، لا كهرباء ولا
وقود، كل شيء مغلق حتى
إعادة جميع الرهائن، واستؤنفت بعض المساعدات والمياه،
ولكن لا يوجد ما يكفي
من الحصار الذي لا يزال قائمًا، وهو ما
تسميه جماعات حقوق الإنسان
عقابًا جماعيًا في بعض الأحيان للمحظوظين.  يجدون ما هو
أكثر من العدس والخبز
لإطعام أفواههم الجائعة، هذه
الأم تستخدم بنطال جينز للنار
لغلي بعض أجنحة الدجاج و[
تصفيق]
العظام تداعب القنابل بحثًا عن الطعام
الآن سكان غزة ينتظرون
هذه اللحظة بيأس  يمكنهم المحاولة مرة أخرى
للعيش في Jama karach على قناة CNN
London